non
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
journal suite à la crise mondiale que
nous subissons une nouvelle hausse
record du chômage avec 12 millions 160
9300 chômeurs supplémentaires la spirale
semble ne pas pouvoir s'arrêter
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
un problème le chômage explose le
plancher et nous craignons des émeutes
dans le pays d'une semaine à l'autre
je fais on va créer des emplois comme
option ok
premières mesures du gouvernement pour
résorber ce chômage record la création
de 12 millions 160 9300 emplois d'hommes
objets pour mieux comprendre
regardons ensemble son reportage de j
-luc seychelles depuis la mise en
vigueur de cette loi des hommes objets
fleurissent dans toute la france focus
sur ces nouveaux emplois que pierrick
qui est gps tourner à droite fait
demi-tour spa parle a fait demi-tour
fait demi tour
c'est un béninois ont fait demi-tour
fait demi-tour là sylvain lui a trouvé
un poste de brosses à dents électriques
chez un coup dans les yvelines
et enfin voici marc antoine qui étaient
en recherche d'emploi depuis plus de
deux ans il peut finalement s'épanouir
pleinement dans une activité de bar de
métro
le climat économique était tendue mais
visiblement la courbe du chômage
semblent indiquer une baisse record du
jamais vu en termes de croissance
un pic historique et christian le marine
vasseur lui les hommes cravate
[ __ ] de merde si les promesses du
gouvernement semble avoir été tenu ces
mesures audacieuses ne cache-t-elle pas
un autre problème
toc toc toc
monsieur le premier ministre nous avons
encore un problème comme le chômage
n'existe plus les quarante cinq mille
employés du pôle emploi ils sont sans
emploi
euh pardon je sais on va fabriquer une
machine à voyager dans le temps aux
arabes ont dans le passé où aller
chercher les chômeurs lumière deux mois
elle renaît dans le présent un hockey
et donc la france est mystérieusement
surpeuplée retour au chômage avec cette
hausse record de 12 millions 160 9300
chômeurs malgré les mesures du
gouvernement
la spirale semble ne jamais pouvoir
s'arrêter voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal on se retrouve lundi passé un
bon week-end
allez à lundi michel et surtout tu sois
une tondeuse